that's focusing on breast cancer
instrumental versus epithelial cells
a little bit about why I chose this
project cancer has always been a topic
of my interest and specifically breast
cancer I have done a few presentations
on breast cancer previously however
those were more clinical based and
focused on pathogenic variants this
article on data set were more of a
molecular focus on the stroma and
epithelial cells which I thought was a
different perspective and would be
interesting to analyze
I also thought it would be a great way
to further dive into the topic by
applying different machine learning
algorithms that we've learned in class
to further understand what is happening
additionally
um cancer can begin any cell in the body
so for that reason it's critical for all
scientists researchers and clinicians to
understand the importance of the various
types of cells and the environment that
these cells reside in using machine
learning algorithms these cells can be
studied and investigated to further
understand disease progression moreover
these techniques can also be beneficial
in evaluating gene expression and
creating accurate models to advance
cancer research the purpose of this
project was to find the significance of
Stroman epithelial cells in normal and
cancerous breast tissues using a variety
of the machine learning techniques to
create a model
the problem slash challenge I decided to
focus on was if we can determine if an
individual has cancer based on gene
expression levels
based on the data set I predict that
regardless of the cell type
epithelial or stromal we will be able to
predict if cancer is present however it
is possible that expression will vary
among features in the epithelial cells
versus the stromal cells
so a little bit on the research next to
skin cancer breast cancer is the most
type of cancer sorry is the most type of
common cancer among women however it can
also affect men there are two main types
of breast cancer known as invasive
ductal carcinoma and invasive lobular
carcinoma and there are three different
parts of the breast that can be affected
which are the lobules the ducts and the
connective tissue
age genetic mutations reproductive
history and family history are all
significant risk factors to the
development and or progression of breast
cancer
the tumor microenvironment consists of
many different components that typically
enhance tumor progression this includes
blood vessels immune cells stromal cells
proteins RNA extracellular Matrix and
more
Additionally the importance of the tumor
microenvironment lies in the fact that
metastasis the spread of cancer cells to
other organs in the body is not is about
90 of the cause for death in patients
with cancer therefore evaluating the
surrounding environment of the body
cells and where they reside is important
to furthering cancer research and saving
patients
the data set that I chose is obtained
from Geo and its ID was GSE
1797 it contained 66 samples and 22 278
genes with three different classes
the associated article was molecular
signatures suggests a major role for
stromal cells and development of
invasive breast cancer and epithelial
cells are cells that cover different
surfaces inside and outside the body
including organs while stromal cells
that make up the connective tissue
connecting different organs and tissues
together
knowing the difference between these two
cells is significant to understanding
their role in cancer and where they
might be found
so my testing methods included a few
which I will further explain in the next
slide but I have them listed here as PCI
which is principal component analysis
lazy predict Model Auto encoders random
forest model confusion Matrix feature
significance and one that I do not have
listed is decision tree but that is also
one of my testing methods that I
included
principal component analysis or PCI is a
method used to determine similarity
between different groups seen by
clusters of the groups within the plot
lazy predict model is a method used to
obtain a classification report that
illustrates the accuracy a specific
models ultimately telling us which model
is best for the data autoencoders are
method used to represent the most
important or useful information from a
data set representing a neural network
which is trained according to the
provided data set random forest model
and confusion Matrix are two methods
used to visualize and classify the data
feature significance is a method used to
determine which features or genes within
the data set are most significant based
on the given model
now for my results the first result
obtained was the PCA plot which shows 26
explained variance
with the lower percentage of variants
explained we see that there is no clear
distinction between the three groups as
the normal cells are scattered among the
stromall and epithelial cells
thus further refining for analyzing
needs to be done to obtain clear results
next a little lazy predict model was
done so that we could obtain a
classification report which shows us the
accuracy and time taken for various
models the first image shows numerous
different models while the second image
shows the top five models we can see
that the decision decision tree
classifier takes the least amount of
time while having the greatest amount of
accuracy and F1 score
Ada boost classifier also reports
similar accuracy in F1 score to decision
tree classifier but comparatively takes
much longer
the next three models also show lower
accuracy and F1 scores compared to the
first two that were mentioned
these images show Auto encoding with 100
features which are the top two images
and 50 features for the bottom two
images this was done using the tanh
optimizer and with 100 features we can
see a 90.34 variance explained with the
test and trained data at an at a mean
absolute error of about 2.6 and
additionally in the PCA plot 400
features there's a clear distinction of
the cancer stromal cells another
Optimizer really was attempted to be
used however the results were unclear
but with no clear separation happening
in the second plot with 50 features
there is definitely more Improvement
that can be done with the optimizers and
with this Auto encoding but that could
also be done with future work
and further analysis to continue this
research and study
this is a confusion Matrix which was
done to help visualize and classify the
data from the model we can see that
there is misclassification within all
three groups
um therefore to create a better better
model I decided to combine the cancer
cell types and compare cancer versus
normal this resulted in a second
confusion Matrix which I will show in
the next two slides
before the next confusion Matrix I have
a decision tree which
um shows the splitting of the cells when
they're classified so if a feature has
less than or equal to has a value of
less than or equal to 3.448 then it will
be classified as cancer epithelial and
cancer epithelial can further be
just distinguished into either cancer
deal if it is or if it's not that it
gets classified as normal
this is a second confusion Matrix that I
was talking about
um to further refine the data and here
we can see that there's no
misclassifications within the cancer
group as all 28 correctly classifies
cancer while as in the normal there is
some misclassification two of them
misclassify as cancer but three do
classify correctly as normal
and this was the feature significance
that I included to help show us the top
features that were obtained from the
models that I used the top 10 features
that are listed across the x-axis are
correlated to the genes that I have
listed here these are not all the same
genes that were obtained from the
article so further research would need
to be done to either clarify or create a
comprehensive list of which genes are
most significant
so through these methods and Analysis of
the data I've learned that while there
are significance in the type of cell
within the breast tissue there are also
other factors that contribute to
distinguishing between a normal or
cancerous cell those other factors will
need to be further explored as within
this project I focused on creating a
better better model for the cancer
versus normal cells additionally it was
found that compared to the significant
genes found by the differential gene
expression model done by the authors
there are other genes based on my model
that showed significance in the improved
classification confusion Matrix this
points us to the fact that their variety
of genes that are affected within the
tuber microenvironment and with other
machine learning analysis we can refine
the list of genes and find commonalities
using and testing different algorithms
is important so that we can compare the
results that are yielded and continue
finding more discoveries
overall the main takeaway is that while
molecular analysis is not as common for
gene expression of cancer cells we're
able to find significance in shriminal
cells and their presence in breast
cancer and hopefully with using more
techniques and different ones we can
find models that have greatest accuracy
overall the prediction was supported by
the results as a based on my model
different genes resulted as the most
significant compared to the ones found
by the model by the by the model from
from the authors in the article this
shows how various genes can be involved
with expression of breast cancer through
epithelial cells and cancer breast in
cancerous breast tissue these findings
will be helpful for science research as
these techniques can be used for other
cancers and evaluating the effect of
stromal cells in relation to disease
progression thus for further studies
different algorithms can be tested on
this data to dive further into the
comparison of the cell and tissue types
ultimately the goal is to find the best
technique that provides an accurate
model to support the data and Advance
the predictions
next steps would include working with
these findings and continue to work with
code that can further analyze the data
to find better models and ultimately
have better accuracy